well sean listen we are always excited
to get new music from you of course uh
and i just think you are such an amazing
storyteller so my first question for you
is what's the story behind when you're
gone what inspired you
yeah i mean when you're gone is really
about a
breakup and
um
i think in a lot of ways
it was just
me kind of processing um processing what
it feels like to be
on my own again and processing what it
feels like to kind of learn how to cope
and be there for myself
[Music]
the original song was really actually
sad ballad and then it ended up just
turning into an up-tempo song so it's
interesting wow which do you prefer do
you prefer pouring out your feelings in
a ballad or do you appreciate enough
tempo because i don't know you kind of
get to shake off the blues a little bit
i think
if you can surround a song
in a in a sonic soundscape that makes
people excited it like
allows people to listen more you know
and you have some words in this song
that i feel like will resonate with a
lot of people including this lyric you
say hold on i don't want to know what
it's like when you're gone i don't want
to move on so i'm curious like as
someone who um you know has music as a
platform to kind of work through their
feelings at what point do you make it
through the other side is it when you're
writing this and you're like oh man this
is this is it or is it when it belongs
to the fan i think
like the thing about records is that
they're they're kind of a stamp in time
and when you write them that's that's
kind of exactly how you were feeling in
that moment on that day
but they exist forever and i think
that's the beautiful part about them but
um for me
it's
something that
is was always being worked through
before and after the song i think for me
sharing music and sharing vulnerable
kind of lyrics has always been important
to me because
potentially there's someone who's going
through the exact same thing and i think
it's kind of creating a um
a world where somebody can feel related
to and and
less alone and that's what this song
does because i feel like everyone can
relate to you know having that person by
your side through a lot of stuff and all
of a sudden they're gone so i'm curious
you know who would you say you have
turned to when you are going through a
difficult time like this or who or what
has helped you during these times
a lot of people i have a lot of great
people around me and i think that's the
that's the beautiful part is is that
you know
i felt like maybe i was putting too much
pressure on one person to provide every
support that i needed and then i
realized that's why you have such a
great
you know group of friends and family and
all these people are there to support
you and just kind of
be a part of that that journey with you
and and so yeah so many people now for
sure you know you gave fans a taste of
this new song and a tick tock where you
were like moonlight you were moonwalking
shirtless
[Music]
but you said this is unusual behavior
what was unusual about it because we we
are used to a shirtless sean moment
yeah but i used to share this shawn
who's moonwalking no i thought it was i
think you need to do more of that
actually yeah
that's unusual behavior it's unusual for
that to be caught on camera too
do you find yourself kind of i don't
know dancing around shirtless when
you're playing a new song like you just
finished recording
it depends i guess
[Music]
oh well talk to me about this music
video because you filmed it in toronto
and austin right yeah yeah what was that
like i mean for me it was really just
like important to be
filming
the fans and filming me with on stage
and me
kind of rehearsing and stuff i i just
wanted to
get get back to a place where people
were feeling
the musicianship of me and
you know
i feel so excited about tour and i
wanted that same excitement about tour
to kind of come across in this music
video for people you know okay speaking
of the tour that's happening this summer
what are you most looking forward to
about getting back on the road and
seeing your fans in person
i think for me i got to play a show a
couple weeks ago that you saw in the
video
i really learned that
tour is is this one half of the of the
picture with uh with my career and and
what i'm so in love with
and it's it's touring and it's and it's
making music and
when i'm left with just one there's
always this feeling of emptiness and
when you know so when i got back on
stage i really felt like this hole was
filled again and this was like oh i
forgot that like this is truly what i
live for this is something that makes me
feel electric this is something that
really
is
is so special to me so
i'm just really excited for that to
happen again because i think
everybody needs that it's touring is a
special thing it's so special what would
you say is the most special thing about
touring
i think like getting
people
together and
present at one moment over and like
connecting over one thing um
it's a very human experience it's where
it feels like
you and ten thousand other people are
all going through something similar
right at the same time and and the
energy like i think if you ever stand in
an arena you can just feel your your
energy rise and your heart start to beat
faster and it just is like something
that you only get from you know like
tour like a concert or like a sports
game and they're very similar in that
aspect but there's only two things in
the world that give me that feeling you
know yeah it's almost like a really fun
i don't know like group therapy right
you were all going through but also
having a really good time i can't wait
to see you back on the road man
yeah what do you want your fans to know
about you know the music that you're
working on for
a possible album what do you want fans
to know about this next era of shawn
mendes
i think people should just take it as it
comes
and not worry too much about what it
will be you know yes i think it's just
like that's what i'm trying to do is not
get caught up in in what i'm what i
should be and just kind of more so
be excited about what i am in the moment
because i have no idea how music is
going to sound that i make it a month
from now
versus today and i don't want to put any
false expectations out there so
take it as it comes and i hope you enjoy
it whatever it is so you don't have this
full calculation in your head and you're
just by then you're just absolutely yeah
i'm definitely just trying to do
whatever feels good and whatever feels
authentic you know
you know obviously uh as press we really
love to ask musicians and artists about
collaborations but i was curious like
the longer you are in this industry and
the more friends you make in this
industry does that become easier you
know to put those ass out to ask your
friends hey do you wanna should we work
on a song together cause i you know i
saw you rub an elbow through ricky
martin at the hospital so i'm wondering
like does that conversation happen in an
atmosphere like that
i think
it it
no matter how who you know in the
industry making songs together has to be
completely organic otherwise it just
feels forced um
and so i never really no matter i never
really text somebody saying hey you know
i rarely will do that hey should we do
this together it's more so it's just
like we happen to be in the same place
at the same time and
time kind of aligned and here we are in
the studio making a song and that's when
i feel like the best results happen i
remember with khalid i was friends with
khalid for three years before i actually
ended up ever hanging out with him and
we ended up creating a song called youth
which i'm so
proud of but
i think that's when the best results
kind of happened what do we have to do
for mariah collab because we know you
guys are fans of each other we know she
texts you now
i'm not not much i mean i wouldn't be
surprised if that happened
[Music]